[Music]
our first panel participant is a
professor of physics at Princeton
University in addition to his studies of
gravitational collapse black hole
mergers and cosmic singularities he
designs algorithms to efficiently solve
Einstein's equations on large computer
clusters
please welcome France before the next
participant is an assistant professor in
the gravitational waves physics and
astronomy center of California State
University Fullerton she has developed a
widely used model for dense matter
inside neutron stars she's the senior
lead on the extreme matter group within
the LIGO scientific collaboration
please welcome Jocelyn Reed also joining
us is the lead astrophysicist in the
LIGO scientific collaboration she
directs the Center for interdisciplinary
exploration and research in astrophysics
at Northwestern University where she is
the distinguished professor of physics
and astronomy
please welcome viki colore Guerra in our
final participant this morning is a
professor of physics at Syracuse
University whose research involves using
gravitational waves observations to
understand the nature of the universe
please welcome Duncan Brown
you know suppose that some somebody from
some alien civilization a very advanced
civilization comes to earth and asks us
how good are you what have you achieved
then one very good way to answer them
would be we have detected gravitational
waves from merging black holes and
neutron stars and the reason that this
would summarize in an extraordinarily
good way our achievement is that number
one on the theoretical side it will tell
these people that we have reached a
situation where we understand already
that space-time is not just the backdrop
of cosmic events as was once thought but
it's actually an active participant and
space-time can stretch it can curve and
warp and that gravity is not we also
understood that gravity is not some
mysterious force acting across distances
in space but rather it is an expression
of the curvature of space-time so the
Sun you know as if it's standing on on a
trampoline or something it's warping
space and then the planets find the
shortest paths in that curved space
that's what gravity is all about so this
is on the theoretical side then on the
experimental side the fact that we have
detected these gravitational waves will
tell this alien civilization that we
have reached such a level of technology
that we are able to detect displacements
that are thousands of times smaller than
the size of the proton which is really
astounding when you think of this so
with this one sentence we have detected
gravitational waves from merging black
holes we would tell these civilizations
where we have reached so let me start
with France and we could say I will make
this statement and he will tell me if or
if I'm right they buy the LIGO discovery
of gravitational waves from merging
black holes this actually was the very
first direct discovery of an Einstein
black hole am i right yes yes I agree
and it's actually that the history of
black holes is fascinating you know
that's probably most people here know
Einstein no EGP came up with a therapy
on the TV finally after many years in
1915 and within a few months call swatch
all discovered the first black hole
solution the first theoretical solution
that describes what we know of as black
holes today and no one took that
seriously it was such an absurd solution
it predicted so many things that people
couldn't understand even Einstein
thought it was just a mathematical
oddity and then in the 60s and 70s
though when perhaps what several people
including keeps on called
the Golden Age of black hole physics
theoreticians finally got an
understanding what the solution
represents and yes there are a lot of
bizarre things about it but we sort of
understood it that it's actually perhaps
not quite as strange as what people
thought then astronomers also discovered
various objects in the universe which
was very mystifying if they weren't
black holes these are great handy dates
good candidates but then it's sort of a
strange thing happen if you thing like
that the doubt that was there in the
scientific community about black holes
then from the 60s and 70s when these
objects ought to be discovered it almost
went completely the opposite that black
holes became this thing which almost had
to be there it was almost oh boy what
else could there be out there but if you
think about it until this like our
discovery what evidence what scientific
evidence that we actually have that
there really are black holes are
described by Einstein's theory and by
that you mean really
this extreme warping of space-time right
the extreme warping on so in the sense
that so what the evidence that there was
before was there was I'd say there was
incontrovertible evidence that they were
very dense compact massive objects out
there but that there was no direct
evidence that they were black holes of
jenandtony other words these
manifestations of space and time where
space and time is so warped that event
horizons formed but then with ligers
discovery we saw the gravitational waves
coming from this warping of space-time
around to merging black holes to me that
was the most astonishing thing about
seeing their data for the first time is
it was the first direct evidence for
black holes as described by the theory
of relativity right just to continue on
the trampoline example and black holes
they were think so extremely that they
all essentially punch a hole through the
drum so this was the evidence for that
just Lee neutron stars are extraordinary
intense objects in fact one cubic inch
of neutron star matter as a mass of
maybe a billion tons or thereabout
now you take such two neutron stars and
collide them so it's a little bit like
an accelerator experiment only on a
cosmic scale there are so little bit
about that yes so so neutron stars are
the remnants left over after massive
stars not quite massive enough to
collapse to a black hole reach the end
of their lives and they come packed down
into some the core of the star is more
than the mass of the Sun about
one-and-a-half times the mass of our Sun
but compact down into a region about the
size of Manhattan
so it's this phenomenally dense object
and one of the interesting things about
these dense objects is that we don't
exactly know what happens at their
course so the matter in neutron stars is
denser than
any physical matter you might be
familiar with so dense that we don't
anymore have nuclei with electrons sign
of fuzzing around them but the nuclei
have been compressed so close together
that a neutron star is almost like an
atomic nucleus the size of a city let me
just stop you for one second so
basically if you take a normal atom the
size of the atom
is about a hundred thousand times bigger
than the size of the nucleus but in this
case you have compressed everything so
much that the nuclei touch each other
there is no more that space of one
hundred thousand times
please go on yeah so so we have this
this bizarre form of matter and it's
possible when we get to these densities
we're still describing standard model
physics but we don't understand how to
translate that into what happens and it
might not be that there are protons and
neutrons like nuclei anymore but there
are just direct quark matter interacting
with itself in ways that we can't create
and reproduce in any terrestrial
laboratory so these cosmic accelerators
smashed neutron stars together they take
some of the densest matter and the
gravitational waves trace out the
dynamics of this collision and then they
collide and they throw out the source of
an array of electromagnetic counterpart
observations in this really dramatic
this dramatic kind of event that we now
for the first time observed so we see
the traces of the the densest stable
objects of the universe in this panoply
of observations works just for those who
don't know are the fundamental particles
that make up protons for example there
are three quarks that make up a proton
and so on in this case you really reach
those densities where the quarks
interact you know with each other and so
on Vickey so we're talking about
collisions of black holes of neutron
stars in this but how do these systems
form at all how do we get to this
situation which you know then we have
something to collide well theoretical
astrophysicist have ideas about how
these systems form but we don't have the
perfect answer to your question so over
the years we we have developed some
hypotheses for how this can happen in
nature what we know for sure is that it
happens in nature we know that these
binary systems - black holes in orbit
one around the other just like the earth
is going around the Sun but now imagine
two black holes or two neutron stars
like as dense as Jocelyn was describing
in orbit one around the other exists in
nature and the way they might form is
there are two classes of potential
formation mechanisms one is you take two
stars that are formed they are born in
pairs they are born one going around the
other unlike our Sun which is a single
star yeah but about 50 percent or so of
all stars or exactly so we know from
observations with regular telescopes
that most of the stars out there
actually are born in pairs so they they
are born in pairs and they start burning
the nuclear fuel they're producing light
they they're gonna go through the
nuclear evolution eventually their cores
are gonna collapse and depending on the
mass if they're extremely massive 20 30
50 times the mass of the Sun then
they're gonna form black holes if
they're lucky enough then at the time of
the formation the two black holes will
stay in orbit and the system will not
disrupt and then you're gonna get a
binary or you might get a binary with
two new twisters and then eventually
they're gonna come together in these
spiral dance they're gonna keep going
one around the other emitting
gravitational waves which now we have
detected and then they have no other
option but to collide together so this
can happen with black holes or neutron
there's a whole other class of formation
channels that broadly speaking can be
described in the following way you can
be in a extremely dense stellar region
not the kind of region we live in
thankfully otherwise we won't have a
quiet planet like we have it but there
are parts of the galaxy where stars are
extremely packed together in a small
volume so you have a collection of stars
we call them clusters of stars and then
the stars may be individual stars and
they're gonna go through their nuclear
revolution and eventually they're going
to form the Death remnants neutron stars
or black holes those especially the
black holes are going to be end up being
the heaviest objects in that cluster and
as imagine I guess in a glass of I don't
know I'm thinking a glass of milk with
heavy I don't know so the hellish stuff
sinks to the bottom of coffee coffee
beans covered with chocolate so so
they're gonna sink in the bottom because
they're the heaviest things and as they
sink in the bottom they're also moving
at high velocity and they're interacting
together and they can actually even
though the black holes were formed
separately they can actually combine
together into pairs and then eventually
with the emission of gravitational waves
they're gonna end up colliding so you
have pairs that were born starts
together and they stayed together all
their lives and others that went through
the dance floor they had many pair many
partners along the time the time of
their lifetime and eventually they
collided with some partner let me just
add one thing to both of their comments
and that is I mean they both described
stellar evolution and in stellar
evolution stars basically spend their
lives trying to fight gravity if you
don't have any opposing force everything
because of gravity will collapse to the
center so stars spend their life trying
to fight gravity and they do that by
doing nuclear reactions that per
a lot of energy and they which builds a
lot of pressure and that holds you know
them against gravity but as they go
through their nuclear fuels at some
point they ran out of fuels and then
gravity finally has the upper hand and
that believes it eventually to these
collapse which forms neutron stars or
black holes Duncan I saved that
experimentally you are the closest from
this group to very mental sighs what
does like we're doing how does he do it
sure so like OSA is it's basically a
very very precise ruler for measuring
for measuring length and and to give you
an idea of how precise think about the
you know you have these two black holes
or neutron stars going around each other
many many many billions of light-years
away producing these ripples in
space-time and the physical effect of
these ripples in space-time is to
stretch and squeeze space itself so
gravitational waves you know weak
gravitational waves are probably passing
through this room right now stretching
and squeezing everything in this roof
but they're so tiny that we don't notice
you know 40 for us there's no nearby
binaries producing gravitational waves
that you would feel so the the
stretching and squeezing so you gave an
analogy that that over a couple of miles
here measuring a distance that is a
change in distance that let that is less
than the size of a proton or another way
of saying that if you think about the
distance between the Sun and the nearest
stars of the Sun which is about four
light-years or so you're measuring that
distance to the width of a human hair so
that's how precise the measurement has
to be to detect these incredibly weak
gravitational waves and so lie to itself
is both simple and complicated it's
simple in the sense that it's an
experiment that you can build as an
undergraduate in the lab you take a
laser beam you shine it through a a
mirror that's partially silvered and so
half of the laser beam goes this way and
half of the laser beam goes the other
way you put another mirror at the end no
the mirror at this end in this L shape
you bounce the light back so the light
comes back towards the what we call the
beam splitter this this mirror that
split the beam and then the light leaks
out towards a
light detector here a photo detector
right here and if you set this up so the
the lengths of those two arms are
perfectly balanced then you can set it
up so if in Lego we think classically we
think of light as a wave and you set
this up so the the peaks and troughs of
the waves line up and so you get what we
call constructive interference coming
back towards the laser and destructive
interference going towards the photo
detector so the lighter active
interference is when the light from the
two things amplifies each other and
distractive is when it kills each other
right and so all the light comes back
towards the laser when the thing is
perfectly balanced as a gravitational
wave passes through it stretches one arm
and squeezes the other arm and so it
upsets that perfect length balance
between these two arms now in reality
these arms are two and a half miles long
with 40 kilogram mirrors at the end of
each arm so it's a gravitation wave goes
past it changes this delicate balance of
the two arm lengths and some light just
leaks out towards this photo detector
and that light the light that's leaking
out towards the photo detector encodes
the length change which encodes the
ripples and space-time which are the
gravitation wave signal they hit these
things with miles long arms and they
measure everything changing by the
length of a proton I mean this is the
experiment this is why I said if you
tell somebody we have achieved this you
know there is nothing more dramatic that
you can say that we have achieved from a
technological perspective it is Mario it
is actually the most precise measurement
we've ever made humans in any in any
field of science and economics yes and I
think coming back to a question to franz
if you know have we directly detected
black holes you know we I think everyone
believes there was firm evidence for
black holes for observing the light
given off as material falls into black
holes or the light given off by stars
orbiting black holes but with LIGO you
actually those gravitational waves those
ripples in space came from the black
holes themselves so this machine reached
out and touched the event horizon of
those black holes with a machine that we
built here on earth right so France
we've now talked a little bit about how
these things emit gravitational waves
and whatnot and so on and these are
these perturbation in space time there
are a little bit
about that and also tell us a little bit
about how do you simulate what happens
in these things right right so their
guesses people have talked about and
Duncan so these gravitational waves are
ripples in space and time so Einstein's
theory of general relativity it's not a
theory about a force of gravity it's a
theory about space and time and it says
that space space and time or space time
can be described by a geometric
structure distances by things separated
by a certain amount of space or
distances in time we're moving in time
as we speak now and when I turn past
unfortunately and so and what isin
theory says so you know like what Mario
described in the beginning I mean I
think you sort of think something like
the earth or the Sun is producing this
sort of this band sheet which would have
represents the curvature of space-time
but when when objects accelerate when
they move in one example of acceleration
is two black holes or two stars orbiting
each other or their earth going around
the Sun we're actually producing
gravitational waves right now but that
kind of acceleration produces these
little ripples in in the geometry of
space and time they propagate out at the
speed of light and as the duncan was
mentioned the exact details of how of
the shapes of these ripples encodes what
produced them so you can imagine you're
just some two things going around like
that that produces a very nice
sinusoidal pattern in the wave let me
just stop you for one second one of the
things about Einstein's theory is that
gravity doesn't act instantaneously it
propagates at the speed of light so
these disturbances propagate at the
speed of light that is a very important
feature of Einstein's general relativity
please go on so so that that purpose
brings to one problem with something
like LIGO in the same set as what Duncan
described it's not a telescope but it's
not focusing gravitational waves on to
an image so we can sort of see what
things look like in gravitational waves
perhaps a better analog is a psycho
seismometer there's something that
produces an earthquake in States Bay
sometime these ripples propagate and
LIGO measures these little fluctuations
so now I say okay we've seen some ripple
what does that mean what does it
represent how can we say that it's two
black holes that collide it was two
neutron storms that are collided and the
way that we do that is we try to solve
the Einstein equations using various
theoretical tools pencil and paper
methods computer simulations and try to
predict what einstein's theory says for
each one of these systems and vary the
parameters of the system and then when
then for the events at LIGO saw we take
these waveforms these little ripples and
we try to match them up to our various
predictions and when we get good matches
we can say the parameters that went in
the simulations that is how interpret
there may be we can have the video and
so here you have these two objects and
they spiral around each other and you
can see that they are getting closer and
closer and they emit these ripples which
are these gravitational waves and the
frequency of the waves becomes higher
and higher the closer they get together
and eventually boom they merge together
and in the case of neutron stars they
produce this thing which we happen to
call a killer nova simply because it's
about a thousand times brighter than
what we call a normal nova and basically
that's what we have seen so please go on
the problem with these simulations the
Einstein equations are very very
complicated and that's perfect for
computers they don't care about
complication except it just takes a lot
of processing power a lot of computers
so for example to do an actual
simulation like something like that
which lasts for perhaps a few dozen
orbits the merger calculates our
gravitational waves propagate that might
take anywhere from say a hundred
thousand to a few million CPU hours so
your typical like their power in your
cell phone and these days cell phones so
very brightest at home yeah we had like
a million cell phones all working
together for an hour they'd be able to
produce one waveform
can you just address this I mean there
is this thing that is known as the chirp
yes right listen to it we make explain
so I said I get the structure that
signal tells us so what's going on and
for for for binary black holes it's
called a strip waveform and so what's
happening is so now we've got these two
black holes are in orbit so when they're
pretty far apart it's a very nice
essentially circular orbit and I said
you know we get through the sinusoidal
wave and you can actually that's nice
for these black hole mergers because the
frequency that they're emitting at it is
in the audio range so you can almost be
raped LIGO is listening to the sounds of
the universe so say two black holes
they're orbiting at a certain frequency
so it's at when they fall apart it's
essentially monotonic frequency so just
a very pure tone but there's this this
orbital motion produces gravitational
waves and that drains energy from the
system and so that's why two black holes
that are in orbit they're not going to
stay in orbit because they're losing
energy to gravitational waves and the
way that that affects the system is that
they start days they start getting more
more bound they start moving they
spiraling closer to each other so when
they're closer to each other they staff
to go faster in some sense you know now
there's a stronger if you will
gravitational force so they have to
start moving faster so the sine wave
that they're emitting increases in
frequency so if the period decreases and
it also increases in amplitude because
they're going faster but now they're
going faster so they emit more
gravitational wave energy so this is
explained stronger but that the pitch is
higher right
so the so it sort of is this runaway
process and so they they start spiraling
around faster and faster and faster and
eventually they collide and it said it
so if you think alike what what happens
to this monotonic well almost monotonic
way that's increasing in amplitude and
frequency and it says whoop sound like
it does well that's what's called the
chirp and then finally when they collide
together there's that final burst of the
chirp and then very very quickly and in
fact astonishingly quickly the black
hole above the two black holes emerge
into a single larger black hole
and it sails down to a stationary black
hole that's completely quiet it doesn't
emit gravitational waves in velvet final
stage is called the ring down phase you
can almost think of it's like these two
black holes they're busy chirping
because of the motion they smashed
together it's like having taken a bell
and like giving it a big sort of if you
hit it with a hammer
now bowels are very efficient at ringing
they ring they make a good sound for a
long time black holes or terrible
battles it's like 30 people party
together they always stop ringing
immediately which is actually an
astonishing prediction like how can
object stop ringing that quickly with
black holes or like that thank you
now Joslyn I want to ask you something
but I'll just make a small introduction
to my question so that it will become
clear so for example on earth we have
tides and the tides are because of the
moon basically what happens is that the
point that is closest to the moon feels
a little bit of a stronger gravity than
the centre of the earth and so the sea
goes a little bit higher similar thing
happens at the farthest from the Moon
point because there it's the center of
the earth that moves a little bit
further so still the the Seas higher now
believe it or not these two neutron
stars even though they only are they
have a mass a little bit large larger
than the Sun but they're just six miles
you know in radius they still when they
get very close they can raise tides like
this so tell us a little bit about this
and how can you we tell whether there
are tides or not yes so as as France
said so the the gravitational wave is
draining energy from the system and
that's and then so that's changing how
the orbit happens and then slowly as the
Stars get closer and closer together
different features of the stars come
into play in the dynamics of how they're
orbiting so when they're far apart the
only thing that really matters is their
mass depending on the mass of the star
though they'll
orbit at a particular frequency and the
frequency changes in a particular way as
they get closer the influences of their
spins and how different the masses
starts to come into play and then as
they get very close to each other the
Stars tides become more and more
significant and what happens is in
addition to energy being drained away by
the gravitational waves some of that
energy goes into deforming the star so
you can think of a star at rest has a
certain energy and to deform the start
to raise the tides that changes the
energy it pulls the star out of
equilibrium and that that takes energy
to do so the forming the tides is
another drain on energy and so it causes
the Inspiral to accelerate and then of
course you know there's also a factor
that depending on the size of the star
they eventually crash into each other
and if they're very compact they can do
a few extra orbits if they're large
they'll they'll interfere with each
other more quickly so the chirp at the
very end the pattern of the ripples will
either get accelerated by tides and then
cut off by the Stars smashing together
or if the stars are very compact the
tides are weaker the it's harder to
disrupt a very compact star than a
larger fluffier star so that more
compact stars will continue there
there's black hole like our orbit and
then eventually merge in a more
simplified way so right so basically how
how much you can deform the star by
these tides depends on whether we call
this the equation of state basically it
depends on how hard it is to deform it
how you know how does it respond to
trying to change you know by applying
the force to it how trying to change
that
so basically isn't it true that what
happens is that these tides at some
level tell us this equation of state I
mean how the
pressure depends on the density of the
star and so on right so so we're trying
to find out what are the properties of
the mysterious matter in the core of the
stars and the key property that we're
interested in is at a given density how
much pressure does that matter provides
so this this is matters last stand
against the crush of gravity so it has
to be providing a lot of pressure at a
very high density but if that pressure
is low the collapse happens a little
further and you have a compact star if
the pressure is high you have a larger
star and the larger the star is the
larger the impact of the tides the outer
material of the stars farther away in
it's easier to be disturbed by the tidal
force of the other star so a larger star
deforms more pulls more energy from the
system Vicki we mentioned this a little
bit but I want to get a little bit into
the more nitty-gritty black holes are
you should understand that black holes
are actually very simple objects they
are characterized by two numbers well 3
in principle but one is the mass the
second is the spin how fast they rotate
and the third in principle is their
electric charge but in Astrophysical
objects there is no real electric charge
so it's two numbers basically but from
these things we can try to determine the
mass in the spin and also the
orientation of the spin namely is it
rotating around this axis or that axis
and so on well and also things like the
distance and things like that walk us a
little bit through how do you determine
all these parameters from the
observation yes so it goes back to what
I think Franz mentioned it first the the
chert okay so all this information about
the mass and the spin and the distance
of the source of these death spiral
dances and eventual collisions and the
tides
all encoded in that share we're
observing with the gravitational wave
detectors what we measure directly is
basically the squeezing and stretching
and squeezing and stretching of the
space-time here on earth which is the is
the propagation of the wave that started
from the source when the wave is
reaching us it's disturbing our
space-time here and what we measure is
the amplitude of the wave we measure the
frequency of the wave and we also
measure the duration of the wave and
during that duration of the signal the
frequency is not steady but it actually
changes so we can measure what we call a
frequency derivative so the frequency of
the wave is not a simple sinusoid as you
were saying but the the peaks of the of
the sinusoid are coming closer and
closer together rate of change rate of
the frequent the frequency is changing
and we can measure the rate with which
the frequency is changing so we have
amplitude frequency and frequency
derivative so the rate of change of the
frequency so these three are the
fundamental measurements we make and and
we can use these three fundamental
properties with a little bit extra
information that is hard to get into
right now but these are the three main
things that allow us to decode masses
spins in the distance because the
amplitude of the wave is telling us
something about how far away is the
source and also how massive the objects
are and the change of the amplitude with
time and the change of the frequency
with time is also telling us something
about the spins
sometimes not always sometimes we can
restrain the spins but sometimes we get
very weak constraints on the spins maybe
we can have an image just so in the case
of the neutron stars in particular we
also observed this in
ultraviolet light optical light and so
on and we have an image of what was
actually observed with a swift
experiment so look in that box and you
will see that thing which suddenly well
you see the period disappearing it's in
a galaxy that's well has a telephone
number of 40 to 993 and so on but so
just realize that everything they told
you these are things that happen
sometimes billions of light years away
so this is the type of thing we see and
it is from that type of information that
you get all these details that you see
here and that leads me to you Duncan
because in this case of the neutron star
merger or there was somewhat of a mishap
in that in one of you see they have this
alert system or when something happened
because they want to alert other
telescopes and this and that
when this neutron star merger happened
it the alert worked in one of the
locations but not in the other tell us a
little bit of what happened then that's
right so so to set the context as front
said gravitational wave detectors are
like listening to the universe you're
listening to the the sounds are spaced
on the ripples and gravitational wave
detectors don't just look in one
direction they look in all different
directions so just like my ears can hear
sounds from all over this room if
someone over there made a noise then I
could say okay might my brain can
localize the be the sound it's coming
from over there and I can turn I can
point my eyes and I can look over there
and I can see what's going on and that's
what we wanted to do with with
gravitational wave detectors and
electromagnetic telescopes we wanted to
say let's listen out for a gravitational
wave signal coming from somewhere on the
sky somewhere out there in the universe
and then when we hear this signalling
gravitational waves - then say point
telescopes over there and look over
there and see if you can see light in
all its different forms coming from
these two objects colliding so we had a
system that was set up that would alert
us to these these these gravitational
wave detection
and in order to figure out where sounds
are coming from I have two ears in a
very complicated signal processing unit
inside my head so I can I can detect and
I can localize sources with
gravitational wave detectors we have
three detectors there's the two us like
oh detectors one in washington state one
in livingston and then there's a french
italian detector just outside Pisa in
Italy so these three detectors make a
network and the idea is they triangulate
on the sky where where the source is and
so you can say gravitation wave over
there go look and so they all have to
work together all three detectors have
to work together in order to figure out
where the source is like my two ears
have to work together unfortunately what
happened was these gravitational wave
detectors are incredibly sensitive
instruments mean as we said you're
measuring changes in length that are
smaller than a proton and the real world
is a noisy messy dirty place things
glitch things paying there's all these
complicated control loops to keep the
detector stable and what happened on the
the morning of August 17 when we when we
detected the binary neutron star is the
LIGO Hanford detector one of the
detectors is computer software that
scans continuously for these patterns
these chirp patterns of gravitational
waves looking for these signals in the
detector data and the software that was
looking at the Hanford data in
Washington State said I think I've seen
something really interesting you should
take a look at this and it sends out
alerts to people's cell phones and
emails and people start to get text
messages saying hey hey come and take a
look at this and we looked and I used to
tell my students you know when we
finally see a binary neutron star signal
you know it won't be that obvious will
he'll be pulling out the noise we looked
and it was just obviously clearly I'm
happy to be wrong look you can see the
chip but it was the computers only found
it in the Hanford detector
they didn't find it in Virgo and they
didn't find it in Livingston which is
key to knowing where on the sky that it
is and so this is where the humans come
in this is why people get PhDs and spent
many years trying to understand what's
going on these detectives and figuring
out what's going on so the humans came
along they said okay we have to take
over the computers or failed us
that's going on and and we realized very
quickly a team of people who've
dedicated large fractions their lives to
understanding how these detectors work
realize that there was a glitch what we
call a glitch in the limited in Texas
like having a scratch on a record or a
CD you're listening to the music needs
something hear a click and the computers
are trained to ignore clicks and pings
and things that don't look like
gravitation away so they set out we're
ignoring that them line no signal there
nothing to see here
so the humans actually went in and said
no no look we can see a signal in
Livingston we can see a signal in
Hanford there's just this giant glitch
in Livingston at the same time that the
humans can figure out what the computers
couldn't so what we did is we leptin to
action
understood where the glitch came from
this is kind of a frenzied maybe four or
five hours on that morning trying to
figure out where the where you know what
had gone wrong in the instrument how to
remove this and you know excise it from
the detected data we analyzed the data
together with Virgo and Hanford and
Livingston bring the detector from what
the data from all three detectors
together so then finally triangulate the
source and say it's there and send an
email outs of the observing community to
say here's the patch on the sky where we
think this signal is go point the
telescopes unfortunately we must do that
quickly enough that we didn't really
lose that much I think if we'd move very
very quickly telescopes in South Africa
would have been overhead in South Africa
we could have caught some very important
information from the early part of the
the signal so so next time we're going
to do this better but we got pretty much
everything you could have Leakey wanted
to say yeah I want you to say that that
we were as you said we were a little
lucky because we only it took four or
five hours but these only four or five
hours the source was in the southern sky
and those early for five hours was
daylight in the in the south so even if
we had the early localization it was
still daylight even in southern South
Africa so we were still delayed by a
little bit but we didn't miss the whole
day we missed only maybe a few hours at
the end of the day so it could have been
worse then you imagine here is an event
that was perhaps the most exciting
scientific event in the almost history
of humankind and you read a glitch at
one of those sides of experiments I mean
this is how science works
but humans saved the day yes so anyhow I
want to thank this wonderful panel so
pretty boy
[Music]